[Música]
pra gente falar do futuro do trabalho de
alguma maneira eu tenho que dizer pra
você uma coisa tem o saque o edgar morra
fala por causa do universo significante
que a gente passa por causa do universo
extremamente acelerado que nós passamos
a distribuição digital e esse é o meu
recorte é a gente passa a ter que lidar
com coisas que não têm precedentes
históricos o que acontece eu não vou
discutir currículo porque se você ainda
tem nenhum eu sugiro que joga fora daqui
a pouquinho no próximo intervalo topa
porque não interessa saber o que você
fez pra trás quando o universo nele
conspira de uma maneira diferente então
a questão do tempo que é a
hipermodernidade a questão tensa do
tempo é que o novo universo elevado pelo
tempo hoje o antigo universo deste lava
o tempo então a pegada é completamente
diferente do que a gente tem hoje
então é a tradicional dinâmica
competitiva que a gente tem hoje é
completamente diferente do que as
empresas de alguma maneira operam é
porque o que tem no centro uma carga
violentíssimo de mudança como se fosse
uma bomba de nêutrons é nunca gente
viveu tanta mudança todo o tempo por
causa desse ambiente exponencial que a
gente vive e temos três coisas que não
conseguimos reconhecer primeiro a
velocidade exponencial a amplitude das
mudanças ea profundidade que ela tá
acontecendo nunca passamos por isso em
toda a humanidade né e isso faz com que
as equações de trabalho mudem é mas de
forma muito radical comparando com o que
a gente foi no passado bastante recente
as empresas que vão sobreviver no século
22 léo 21 aro 22 serão aquelas que vão
conseguir fazer coisas muito simples
primeiro pensar de forma digital
não pensamos pensamos de forma analógica
ter uma identidade digital não tenhamos
nenhuma e que possam criar uma economia
digital
de alguma maneira todo mundo quer criar
uma economia digital mas não quer pensar
digital e aí na transformação digital as
pessoas e as empresas cometem crimes
gravíssimos próximo você faz a
transformação digital
quem já tendo clientes no facebook que
não é nada disso que trabalhou pelo amor
de deus não é isso que a gente está
falando de presença digital é muito
diferente do que fazer transformação
digital onde a gente tem fronteiras
entre o mundo físico o mundo biológico
nem no mundo digital que passa a ser uma
instância única é porque a gente hoje
fala que até os próprios wells
tá deixando já é de ter alguma expressão
porque a gente está discutindo interna
bons quando a gente vai ter né é coisas
robôs de vestir e internos porque a
gente já não reconhece mais carne in
vitro peixe in vitro você está preparado
pra comer um bife de um de uma vaca que
não existe copa eu já sei que a sua
mente armou uma armadilha
assim não não tem gosto de corrimão da
escada de rodoviária não isso é uma
imagem mental que você faz porque a sua
cultura não te permite a isso então é de
alguma maneira a gente vai ter sim
mudanças muito radicais no conceito de
trabalho é e aí a gente traz aqui uma
uma nova pegada que nos próximos 20 anos
e esses são dados da da universidade de
oxford é que já fala que 57 por cento
dos empregos em escala global já serão
tomados por robôs
ainda assim aos robôs vão tomar a mim o
meu cargo não vão tomar a minha frente
de trabalho
olha se você estiver fazendo um trabalho
repetitivo eu sugiro que você passa a
pensar a partir de agora fez faz
trabalho repetitivo você pode ter
certeza é que os robôs sim tomaram seu
lugar o que vem pela frente essas
profissões novas completamente novas que
a gente está vendo que são divertidas né
e psicólogo de robôs topa
sim porque eles vão enlouquecer primeiro
eles vão enlouquecer a gente segundo o
que a gente já soube que os botes né é
do facebook há pouco tempo em low que
serão eles começaram a falar uma língua
que só eles entendem uma língua não
humana e olha vou começar a correr até
2032 que disse eu tenho medo né
mas é verdade é uma loucura isso é então
psicólogo de robôs quando a gente fala
assim de fazendeiros urbanos nostalgia
estados porque o nostalgia porque a
gente tem duas fronteiras né
quanto mais o universo fortec mais
tanques seremos quanto mais tecnologia
cortada tivemos mais humano seremos e
isso é um grande paradoxo porque a gente
acha que a gente vai ficar igual os
robôs não vamos a gente vai ter até
tempo para poder viver né esse tempo de
viver se sabe viver a eu do devedor que
alguém aqui saiba viver né
a gente faz tudo errado a gente confunde
emprego com o trabalho confunde tudo
isso com a nossa vida quando você perde
o emprego perde a vida juntos a gente
tem alguma coisa muito errada com a
gente não com vocês eu já sabia disso né
então os nostálgicos fãs vão pensar no
né
no passado que nos acalenta no passado
que traz a visão humana né do cheiro da
terra molhada da chuva a canequinha de
água do bolo da vovó alguma
identificação é cozinhar para os amigos
a tempero orgânico não é isso esse é o
lado touch do nosso mundo tem é de
alguma maneira é nós vamos ter aqui
também vamos ter mudanças sim muito
radicais é no conceito de de emprego
então qual é a grande frase aqui se você
não conseguir ser disruptivo você pode
ter certeza que alguém será por você o
que é fazer disso uma opção é
transformar tudo que você fez até agora
em algo completamente obsoleto
a começar por você se você não conseguir
fazer o que a gente chama de alto
ranking porque no meio de tudo isso tem
você no centro
se você não conseguir fazer auto rádio
em que é transformar você mesmo em algo
obsoleto você não consegue dar esse
salto para frente
ok não consegue a gente precisa muito
menos resiliência e precisamos muito
mais plasticidade conselho de gts porque
as pessoas se perdem isso errou e bateu
na parede recalcular rota né errou o
caminho e calcula rota gente pede para
saber quem foi porque foi quando foi
para isso não adianta mais a gente não
olha mais isso é errar faz parte do
aprender então f-indy rápido r barato e
aprenda o dobro com tudo isso né é super
simples a gente a gente fazer isso né
para o futuro que a gente tem
profissionais muito mais independentes
muito menos chefes gente tudo de bom é
isso que a gente se livre dos chefes pra
sempre né de um aperto o botão eles
somem
vamos ter muito mais tutores
muito menos chefes mentores também vamos
ter né
é a gente sair para o mundo da
colaboração de uma forma muito mais
turbo quando a gente ainda tem uma
batida da competição a competição já não
serve mais se você pega é tudo aquilo
que é filme hoje que a gente vê de
super-heróis né
e vocês devem ver também filmes de super
heróis e podem ver que ninguém mais usa
o conceito de super herói sozinho já
viram todo mundo aqui bando já viram
isso porque são skills complementares
mas se você pensa que é muito fácil ser
super-herói você tem que ter certeza que
todos super homem tem sua criptonita e
você ainda vai ter que vestir a cueca em
cima da roupa ainda vai ter que voar
então não é tarefa fácil pra gente né
é preciso de grandes descentralizadores
ao contrário de gente que quer ter tudo
na mão grandes realizadores
eu quero ter muito menos currículo e
muito mais valores intrínsecos o que eu
olho pra você é o que você significa não
é o que você faz eu quero saber qual é o
poder de hacking pra frente se não tem
precedentes históricos para que eu vou
querer ver o seu currículo
então a gente vai ter também neve e
trabalho se fundem trabalha a extensão
da vida remuneração é consequência ea
maior influência que a gente tem é
residual de tudo aquilo que a gente
consegue né então não me interessa saber
o que você faz só me interessa saber o
que você significa é com esse é isso que
eu vou me conectar e não o contrário
né bom de alguma maneira eu queria dizer
pra vocês eu deixo aqui um super recado
pra todo mundo
cuidado com essa coisa do mundo o
técnico do tec mundo tech porque a gente
pensa que de alguma maneira a gente vai
ser ressignifica é sempre pelo mundo o
técnico que é muito legal é apaixonante
se você está disposto a viver 500 anos
que é isso que já que o recurso vai o
que o vice-presidente inovações do
google e que também tem sobre ele também
o google vende os a gente vai ter que
saber que a fusão um homem máquina cada
vez mais vai estar presente entre nós né
está marcado para 2045 foi antecipado
para 2039
e se você gosta desse novo mundo nem com
a gente mas não esqueça que o lado
humano é muitíssimo mais importante que
o lado tektek é meio vêm e vão todo o
tempo mas as conexões humanas não mas
como eu sei que você tem medo de ir para
esse novo universo eu vou usar uma frase
do campo eu adoro né e joseph campbell
que ele faça o seguinte é o tesouro que
você busca
tá sempre na taverna que você tem medo
de entrar né
então você vai ter que decidir de uma
vez por todas se você vai atrás do seu
sonho se você vai ser aquilo que você
sempre quis se você está fazendo
concessões na sua vida de trabalho você
tem que repensar é isso e se tem alguém
aqui ainda que trabalha porque tem que
pagar a conta eu o trouxe uma
metralhadora e eu vou botar todo mundo
no paredão
tudo bem porque hoje a gente trabalha
com prazer a gente trabalha é com tesão
naquilo que faz
tá bom então eu deixo aqui o recado é
obrigado pela companhia de vocês né
e como bom humano que eu desejo para
vocês saúde paz
obrigado